hey everybody and welcome to a ripping
wild ride with stevo we've got torrey
pudwell he is hands down my favorite
skateboarder on the planet and if you've
seen his new video part bigger bang then
you would know why god this guy is so
unbelievably rad he's a little bushy in
the face with the beard and everything
and i'm okay with that but not
downstairs man not with my bush i like
my pubes nice and clean and that's why i
love manscaped this right here
is the best
men's grooming company for the below the
waist needs and that's a fact plus
they're sponsoring this episode with
such an incredible deal for you if you
get their performance package man not
only do you get the lawn mower 4.0 the
weed whacker you also get uh
anti-chafing
boxers and the shed travel bag it's
unbelievable plus no matter what you get
you're gonna get 20
off your order plus free shipping and
i'm not used to saying discounts like
that because
only manscaped is hooking you up that
much to get this deal you go to
manscaped.com
and you use the promo code stevo if you
haven't tried the lawnmower 4.0 you're
out of your mind it's
it's your pubic bush's worst nightmare
and probably the best thing to help you
get returned customers in the sack
that's right ladies love to groom man
they love it so go to manscaped.com
use the promo code stevo to enjoy 20 off
your order plus free shipping and
remember if you get the performance
package they throw in two free gifts the
shed travel bag and the chaff free
boxers now let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen tori pudwell
yeah dude yeah dude super stoked this is
scott randolph my co-host yeah dude
what's going on dude just before i was
like dude like this is such a big deal
have you seen this guy skate
and uh scott said is he in like your top
three favorite skaters i said he's
absolutely my number one favorite skater
whoa
that's a big statement dude
it is a big statement and uh
um when did you first get on the tour i
mean dude the bigger bang one
tori put out this video part
called big bang that was the one with
the tune how do you like me now you like
me now 11 years ago 11 years ago wow
and it was ridiculous and then he
followed that up with uh his part in
the plan b video true yeah
and i declared that to be the best video
part ever made and that i didn't think
it could be outdone but he has just
outdone himself
with
bigger bang
bigger bang bigger bang yeah so how long
did you work on that part um
four years four years four years yeah um
it's kind of a giveaway that you had
musca in there with no beard dude that
was crazy right uh yeah he pulled up on
me like oh wow that's right he just like
parked illegally and then ran out the
car crept around the corner i was like
oh [ __ ] what up chad yeah yeah like he
was like dude i see you skate man i had
i had to pull over and say what's up you
know super rad dad love moscow so he
came he blessed the spot i was
struggling on that spot and that was
just the trick that you went for that
kick flip frontside 50 yeah like four
different days and that day like moscow
came and like i landed it that day but
yeah four different days yeah how many
times the nature of the of the beast
dude like the level that tori's at well
you know how it is like if you got a
trick that you want like you can't let
it go
no matter how long you spread out that
time it's like
it's always just in the back of your
mind like i gotta go back for it is
there a trick that you've uh never been
able to complete and it's just like or
do you do it until you complete it do
you have a 900
yeah for sure i mean there's there's
tons of [ __ ] that like i could still go
back for it
you know does it keep you up at night it
um
yeah i mean like there's times i i'm
just like i come home i'm destroyed and
like physically and mentally you know
and i'm like i can't i can't sit around
until i go back and i'm there again to
try the [ __ ]
and it's like it's like a an obsession
i found when i was in my like heyday of
skateboarding when i was really really
trying the hardest that when i got
injured and was unable to escape because
i was injured that those periods of time
actually
made me a better skater yeah like time
away and just wanting to skate so bad
and not being able to like just that
pent-up passion like actually translates
into like when you get back on the board
is part of the progression you know it's
like it's it's all part of the process
but it is part of the progression for
sure yeah like like tape being having
skateboarding taken away from you yeah
only makes you better at it right very
well put
now you you had a
like
famously really [ __ ] up your back
what happened with that yeah uh i i
fractured my spine
and um
yeah i mean
it was kind of a weird one because
like
you know what whatever like number
vertebrae it was like you know you crush
those discs yeah and it's like so
painful
um
and
i i just like
went to the doctor and they said there's
nothing we can do to make it better
there's nothing you can do to make it
worse
so if you can tolerate skating still
then
you know that's up to you it's not going
to get worse you're not going to hurt it
more that sounds like a pretty crazy
thing for a doctor to say that was like
one of those rare injuries where i was
just it hurts so bad because that acid
leaks out of your spine and it's just
that pain spinal fluid yeah that's what
that is dude spinal
and final should scare you i uh i yeah i
ended up kind of like powering through
it just like is that still going on to
this day no it's it's good
it's all healed up i mean my whole body
is just like you you how old are you
adjust 32 okay
how did you
how did you break your back um
i just bent over backwards as far as you
could bend over backward trying to ride
a trick out
like uh is there a video where they can
see that happening or um it was in a
contest it was like middle of the
contest
i was just trying to like i basically i
landed instead of landing forward i
landed sideways
but i was like my body was going forward
so i was still trying to ride it out as
long as i could
and um
just crushed yeah crushed the spine
i didn't think it was that bad i still
like skated that day and finished but
afterwards i was just like it was like
hell
yeah hell
summer injuries you know like kick in
an hour later and you're like
where are you at with surgeries how many
skate related surgeries have you had um
four
okay it's pretty minor in the grand
total it's fruity minor for sure um
i uh
i just got surgery six months ago i
broke my ankle
compound not compound bone wasn't
sticking through but uh it was the first
time i got hardware so i got a plate
seventh right i think that means complex
compound doesn't mean it has to be
sticky right okay compound fracture i
think compound just means it's broken
enough that it needs plates and yeah i i
mean i it was like i i busted it man
could you did you did you go to dr
previte
dude doctor pre-bite
he did my first ankle surgery
he did what you did yeah danny took me
to dr previous doctor pre-invites the
man dude he's still doing it huh yeah
you know what i'm not sure that he is
because i think danny uh had a different
surgeon for like his last one
danny's must have had like 30 some
surgeries yeah
yeah it's crazy how many skate related
surgeries have you had
skateboarding related just the one that
danny took me to prevent i i shattered
my ankle with uh
like danny
danny wade for anybody who doesn't know
like he was crashing a car through this
wooden porta potty i was doing a
boneless off of
and uh tony hawk was there filming it
like just
the legends but right there and and uh
and i
wanted to stick it so bad it was the
same thing i just tried to stomp it i
wasn't even on the board but i just
yeah
yeah shattered it yeah pre-bites the man
so uh so only four surgeries two on
ankles yeah two ankles ankle's a better
joint to [ __ ] with than a knee
right yeah have you had knees or knee
surgery too that's a tough one yeah it
wasn't
the acl which is like that one's like
that's like the worst injury you could
have i think that and what i just did to
my ankle
for skateboarding anything on the balls
in the head obviously that's enough
story but um
spine i think is
unique that's unique yeah i'm sure
that's happened to danny
danny
yeah you guys went down to columbia
together and they're probably just like
yeah have you been on the stem cell
mission yet no i've heard about it
though yeah i went on the stem cell
mission with danny too yeah it feels
like for me it was preemptive you know
like i've got degenerative disc disease
in my neck but it's not advanced to the
point where i'm in pain or yeah or like
you know uh limited in my motion
so it's tough for me to to report how
yeah
i mean dude like
those miracles are out there yeah what i
mean sure it's crazy man like my buddy
chuck liddell danny like
everybody swears by the stem cell
treatment so if anyone is interested in
it look up bio accelerator
yeah danny can get you down there for
sure that'd be stoked to have you done
for sure yeah um
now i heard about the stem cells and you
know i i definitely i mean thank god i
haven't got to the point where i'm gonna
need that
now the sooner you get on it the better
because it's like it's uh giving
yourself credit for future yeah
so it's just any time pre-emptive is the
way to go i think yeah i'm straight up
so so physically you're in i remember
like hearing about your back and and
thinking like [ __ ] man it's so gnarly
like here's this
this like
you know just rarefied talent and like
andrea can just take it all away yeah
well it's kind of scary i mean i think
it's scarier like the more it happens to
like like the more you get injured
because like
the first couple times you're like all
right you know this is this is gnarly
this is like the gnarliest thing that's
ever happened to me right um
but then you get better and then if it
happens again you get concerned you're
like oh man like
can i get better this time right am i
gonna get better again this time like
there's never a guarantee on an injury
it's like a ufc fighter that gets
knocked out right glass jaw then they're
slowly in their head you could get taken
out too by like honestly like
like stupid little injuries it's always
something stupid and it's always it's
always because you didn't fully commit
is that fair to say
what to to like
maybe i can't
yeah maybe that doesn't apply to you but
but i know that for me
like it's always like if i don't commit
all the way
that's a guarantee if if you don't
commit all the way like that's how you
can get hurt yeah for sure yeah um and
like yeah i mean dude that that's
something where you're pissed about it
right you get hurt and you're a little
bit pissed about it sure [ __ ] man like
i just blew it but
but you're in
even six months ago broke your ankle
yeah and you got hardware in there but
you're just skating on the hardware
um i just started kind of trying it out
yeah it's so scary ankle hardware
because
if you break your ankle with the
hardware in there then with all the
screws and everything like it it's like
[ __ ] humpty dumpty just shattering
into a thousand dude oh my god man you
want it like they'll tell you like you
like do not
do not break your [ __ ] ankle with
hardware in there because like it was
shattered to us oh my god dude so many
[ __ ] pieces oh dude i'm like just
starting to skate again but like i ain't
tripping i'm gonna actually um i'm gonna
get it taken out yeah
i can get it out after i have to have it
in for a year yeah i'm ready to get my
collarbone hardware out now to get it
out
there
check this out dude [ __ ]
pre-bite
when he took out my ankle hardware
i was like dude [ __ ] just give it
back to me i want to save it oh my god
so you saved my ankle hardware i found
this company
i i [ __ ]
that
you can buy
uh
like plastic [ __ ]
bone models yeah and i sent them the
hardware with the x-ray and they put the
same hardware that came out of my ankle
in this this cool
ankle
statue that's down in my head no way
yeah i'll show it to you oh that's cool
dude so you're hyped on like
this the souvenir i love the souvenir
and i can't wait to get the collarbone
model with my two plates and have it
right next to it you're on to some [ __ ]
yeah hey that's cool because people
could like i don't know they could look
forward to kind of like making a little
piece of art yeah i like their hardware
because i was like [ __ ] i don't don't
give me that [ __ ] back what am i gonna
do with the the plate and screws in a
bag yeah maybe i could like actually
like you know uh incorporate it into my
house or something dude a hundred
percent maybe just use it as like a
little like it's a cool conversational
piece you know it looks so rad dude yeah
you gotta see it
and um and thanks thanks for coming over
here too so i can show you that's tough
the last time the first time we met you
uh we were talking about your you have a
new company right yeah and you're and
you're doing some uh some boards and
stuff yeah how's that going how about
that scott randolph asking a man about
his business dealings i like it and i
gotta say there's a company that i'm so
proud to be an ambassador for it's
called liquid death this company
sponsors skateboarding like no other and
they're saving the world because it's
canned water from the alps in different
flavors sparkling and still and it comes
in these cool infinitely recyclable tall
boy cans
it's just so much
fun the way they make it look like a
beer so that kids get sent home from
school for drinking beer when they're
just drinking water i mean we love it
and plastic really is destroying the
world in a terrible way and liquid death
is bringing death to plastic plus
they're very very
generous to the listeners of the wild
ride podcast if you go to liquiddeth.com
stevo you can order as much water as you
want and as much merch as you want and
pay absolutely nothing for shipping
that's unbelievable water is heavy to
ship they're covering your shipping man
if you don't go to
liquiddeth.como and take advantage of
this offer to support the wild ride
podcast you're out of your mind so hop
to it man get on the liquid death team
because we're saving the world and
free shipping it's epic one more time
liquid death dot com slash stevo
and enjoy now let's talk about business
it's going um we're uh
me and daewon song launched it uh we're
coming up on four years now cool um
which isn't very long they say the
three-year mark is when you start really
hitting your stride for sure uh
it's it's an interesting one because i i
i took on the responsibility to do it
all myself
yeah a lot
it's a lot i started from nothing
and educated myself
uh every thing that goes into running a
business
i mean
like we can really kind of pull the
coverage you know this you know this but
like
for professional skateboarders the
industry standard for compensation on
your pro model skateboard sales is
two dollars per board they'll pay you
two bucks aboard two bucks a board and
that
kind of makes sense when you think of
the in the retail scheme because
if a board costs however much to make
then you got to sell it wholesale to the
skate shops then the skate shops need to
mark it up so there really is but
when you talk about selling boards
direct to consumer direct to consumer
without that wholesale and the markup
for retail then
like the the profit margin that you can
have is and we know this because we saw
imports how much how much would your
board go for
they're trying to give pro skateboarders
two dollars per board on direct to
consumer online sales which makes no
sense at all i can't believe that
they're even trying to do that now right
i mean they should at least
like respect the difference between
retail and online
dude but the the thing is man skaters
don't know that skaters don't think
about it they're finding out and that's
why that's why we are finding out for
sure
for sure in the early days it used to be
like say like the 1980s was it was
the 70s the 80s
the first time
when skaters
like skaters didn't even own skateboard
companies back then george powell was
not a skateboarder brad dorfman from
vision was not a skateboarder like uh
paul schmidt was not even a skateboarder
who was the first one like peralta stacy
peralta was a skater and hit him and
paul george powell i heard but i heard
back in the day those dudes were making
bank off their board sales
i don't know but but i think that's
because there was there was there wasn't
as many pros that's right and and the
boards would be around for like a year
there were very few but bank is what
like 50 grand in the 80s i mean dude the
80s i hated like 50 grand a month dude
yeah i don't know the bones were gay
guys for sure like rock stars dude
the 1980s was a heyday
but then like what happened with like
these these big you know
companies in the 80s that were that were
owned by non-skaters like skaters kind
of got hip to it they were there were
not that many companies but then skaters
started opening their own
starting their own skateboard company
can you give me an example of uh like
like danny way and uh danny way started
plan b yeah after he uh left 8th street
which was started by tony magnussen
skater you know like girl
you know so these were skaters that were
like
yeah i could do it myself
they left plan b
skater and and and all the skaters were
starting littler companies so it was
like this there was like a dynamic of
like rooting for like the little guy
because the the you know you wanted to
root for the companies that were small
and run by skaters because there was
integrity in that yeah but now all these
years later this these skater owned
companies are the big companies and
they're kind of pulling the same crap
that that the the those guys in the 80s
were doing it yeah because it's a it's a
little bit you know
can you just like recap your journey of
like starting a business and being like
whoa [ __ ] uh
you got to do this you got to do that
like what was your experience like
starting this business
let's just first acknowledge the the
incentive here because
like by
and we're seeing skaters do it like p
rod paul rodriguez he he you know
started his own company
which is like the poster company for
success and like you know you could you
could sell one tenth of the boards that
you're selling for that other company
for two bucks a board and
make way more
i mean
dude you know what's crazy too um
with with a lot of
a lot of skaters contracts or whatever
non-contracts
you have to sell through your minimum to
get to that two bucks aboard royalty so
you get paid your salary which could be
you know whatever and if you don't hit
that cap you don't get any board
royalties on your board so if you got
your salary
and board royalty with no minimum like
that's a killer deal dude like that's a
rare deal in skating wow and i got
homies that got that and i'm like dude
like
keep keep that man
i would i would take that because you're
selling boards right now like what's the
minimum board royalty it's it's
basically like let's just say you're
getting paid um uh a thousand bucks a
month right
you gotta sell 500 boards because that
500 boards at two bucks a board that's
going to hit your thousand anything over
uh that 500 boards sold then you'll get
two bucks a boy and that's you driving
all the traffic from your social medias
to their company
um
yeah yeah i mean
at what point were you like dude a
thousand bucks a month is pretty minor
oh i mean board brands like well how
much are they then again they're your
lowest pay and that's the heart of it
that's the core but like man if you
realize like how much money like
you're making the company
it you're almost like damn dude like too
much traffic you're driving to their
website with all your fans now are their
customers and they're making it's like
it's insane but at what point were you
like i can do this better or i should be
doing this by myself
um well you know i i
i never really like was tripping on like
trying to do it for like the cash or if
i could get paid more to do it um i i
just i wanted to start a company to see
if i could do it you know because the
thing is i skated for plan b and danny
way and colin mckay
are like
i mean they're idols to me
and and mentors yeah and i learned a lot
in in that like set yeah we can't talk
anything bad about danny and carl those
guys are no i would never i would never
because i have no reason to right um so
i i didn't leave
because i wanted to you know it it's
it's because
i the only way i could follow a new
dream was that i had to that was the
hardest part
you know but i had the balls to do it
and take that risk and they told me like
yo dude there ain't no money in hard
goods man i'm like
well you know i don't know i think i
could do [ __ ] different i think i could
do this different than everyone else is
doing it and your company is called
thank you called thank you yeah great
name for a skateboard company man but i
i wanted to ask you to bring me some uh
some shirts and [ __ ] oh yeah dude just
like thank you man like that's yeah
that's you know it's it's it's a good
it's a good message for for anyone
anything yeah you know and like
dude it's all about like
you know saying thank you obviously but
like paying homage to skateboarding and
everything that paved the way for me in
day one and like you know i mean dude
i'm sitting with an og right now you
know what i mean like like you you
you've been skateboarding like
since 1985 since the 80s you know what i
mean like doing [ __ ] in the era where
like skateboarding was really cool he's
got to be in your top 30 skateboarders
i mean dude like i say it a lot that um
i mean just the the window of time from
when i was born what happened in my
lifetime i think
that the the invention of the
polyurethane wheel happened in my life
oh [ __ ] birthday i'm not sure when polly
was that like the same time as the
microwave popped up i don't know but
when street skating was born in my life
because it was back in the day yeah in
the 1980s when i was street skating like
it was brand new so i was learning with
the pros like and and here's one thing
that i don't understand like for me when
escape when a skate video came out it
got me pumped to go skate now
when parts like [ __ ] tory's bigger
bang come out like how does a kid
see what you're doing and decide oh man
i'm gonna get into skateboarding like i
don't know like i don't get it like
thank god it was in its infancy when i
was born
do the craziest thing now though is like
the five-year-olds six seven
eight-year-olds that are getting into
skating are so [ __ ] good
five-year-olds skating back then never
existed
especially five rolls they could
kickflip or like wow
shackler was pretty rare rare
very rare and like i mean the talent
these days is crazy i think just because
the level of skateboarding is crazy
that's what they see
i like grew up religiously watching
skate videos she was different we didn't
have the search engine you know what i'm
saying i had it popped into the vhs
right that [ __ ] didn't leave the vhs
player until the next one came out that
was your first skate video that
really got you started that got me
stoked
um
probably the the birdhouse the end oh my
god that one i think what 98 that came
it came out specifically in 1998 and ah
that that one that one tripped me out
dude because like i never seen anything
like that and like just like like they
had skits in there too yeah and skits
that weren't lame they weren't lame you
just you literally you don't know that
this is like a uh you know a planned
thing you guys are acting they got heath
kirchar lighting cigars with 100 bills
and women in the bathtub and you think
that's real like decapitated steve barra
yeah with like the highest level of uh
special effects like
they shot everything on 35 millimeter
but now tony's part they shot in 35
millimeter film they shot most of it on
legit film the whole the whole video
yeah was film i think that was awesome
over a million
it was only like 200 thousand really
that's a lot of money to make a skate
video yeah but then but then that was
before that was back then
it was the first video that came out
that was like on the radar enough that
they got in trouble for music copyright
so they had to like reissue it because
they used like a queen song oh [ __ ] and
then they got like sued for it
and uh yeah i never understood how big
brother never got in trouble for using
mute you know
yeah i don't know ain't on the radar so
it must be like a certain amount of
views where they're like oh boy
yeah and then when the dc video came
along in 2003 they got permission from
metallica for uh
is it dope is 200 i mean 200 dollars is
a lot to make
industry kidding me especially in the
90s like [ __ ] yeah dude paying anything
to make escape videos but that would be
like the most i've ever heard of making
a skate video right is that the the case
i mean i mean that's probably like for
sure on the on the hand
you know yeah because no one shoots a
whole video and film dude remember uh uh
there i think a monkey broke a beer
bottle over reynolds head yeah
dude sure that that absolutely happened
but when you're eight years old watching
that [ __ ] you're like i don't know like
like like it was something that's
implanted in your mind where it's just
like
it's so cool
dude like he's kurt chart did uh
backside noseblind slide the first time
the world had ever seen it steve barrett
did kickflip 5050 on a round handrail
and then now in your bigger bang part
like jesus the
like i don't even know where to begin
with with like the the last part it was
like the longest backside tail side the
world had ever seen was it specifically
the exact same ledge you did the nollie
flip accent tail slide across the whole
thing a different ledge i mean similar
concept to it the little little curve
over the grass the the one i did uh the
backside tail slide that was twice as
long yeah i mean i remember it being
pretty that was that was yeah 84 feet
and dude this is the backside 360
kickflip on flat ground over a picnic
table yeah
how many visits did it take to get that
that was four
visits also
and like like i'm talking like five
hours each time trying it don't stop
most the time when i have to stop is
because it gets dark
i mean even even if i get to a spot at
like 10 a.m
for some reason i'm still trying it till
it gets dark so it's there's no point to
show up any earlier you know like the
day's the day when it happens and and
how high
the
like that that how high that ledge was
with that kickflip backside smith and
just how pronounced that backside smith
was
like oh dude i have like an interest for
the things that i skate you know i like
to skate like
my [ __ ] and and this new part was like
burlier like like it felt like the the
part and true dude the bigger bang was
so technical but now you're like technic
like there's all these like kickflip
cookie grinds on handrails like felt
more dangerous like more burly dude so
what's crazy is
i was watching
your podcast i wasn't even watching
actually like the warehouse homies like
they would just like run podcasts all
day and like i'm working like printing
skateboards
and um they bounce they just leave it
running
and i'm i'm just there on the machine
and like it's your episode with danny
and i i heard you
bring up my name and i was like whoa
that's right i mentioned his name on the
danny episode and i'm sure there's a lot
of people mentioning my name these days
because i've been losing weight again
and my skin looks better and i i just
know that people are saying this all
over the place there's two reasons for
this one i crawled on my hands and knees
back into my food support group because
of my uh terrible addiction to sugar and
compulsive overeating and the other
reason is because of athletic greens i
swear by this product it fills in the
gaps in my nutrition i don't know if
you're eating enough greens or if you're
really getting all of the nutrition that
you need but if you aren't then this is
the answer athletic greens each serving
of this
comprehensive convenient daily nutrition
comes loaded with 75 different vitamins
minerals whole food-sourced superfoods
probiotic and adaptogens i know that's a
lot to digest but thank god i'm
digesting it because it is just making
me glow baby it's also helping with my
gut health with my cognitive skills
because it's good for my brain and again
it is comprehensively filling in all of
the gaps in my diet i swear by it it
couldn't be more delicious
and you
got to try this and you're going to give
you a big deal on it you go to
athleticgreens.como and if it's your
first time there you get five of these
travel packs with the full comprehensive
daily nutrition
and you get an entire year's supply of
immune boosting vitamin d they hook you
up they give you that for free with your
first purchase if you go to
athleticgreens.com
stevo
try it it's delicious i look forward to
it every morning i have it with a pint
of water which starts me off hydrated
you know
can't beat it so one more time
athleticgreens.com
stevo enjoy
thank me later and let's get back to it
whoa whoa whoa wait a second because
because
we we never met each other before so i
was i was kind of like holy [ __ ] damn
how was stevo like really giving me a
call out like that right now and like it
was pretty heavy
you know like i specifically said two
days the most dominating street skater
the most dominating street skater the
best video part the world has ever seen
and uh having never met tory so i have
no reason to try to like kiss his ass or
anything i just feel strongly that
that's like
this this was a couple years ago um and
you said
you said
i wonder if this is gonna haunt tori
to follow this video up for the plan b
true video and when you said that i was
like i didn't think about that before i
was like damn
that's exactly what it is right now
right and and you know what like
that's my motivation that was my
motivation because i was like dude like
you know i don't know man like i i i
gotta i put a lot all my heart into this
stuff you know and like to me it's just
like it's for me you know i do it
because it's like i don't know i i it's
it's heart love it how long did the last
part take you to make which one the true
true that was a solid five years
yeah solid five years yeah and then the
bit the bigger bang one bigger bang was
four years big bang was six months okay
i was i meant to say big bang big bang
was six months and like that was like me
like that was just pure energy i want to
see what i could do in six months you
know and that was the first ever
uh online solo part that was free
no i never gave a video out for free
before that right
on the internet speaking of putting [ __ ]
for free how much like stuff just goes
out on instagram barracks [ __ ] like
you know like it's crazy
the level of skateboarding that these
days people have what they say for their
part and then what they also just throw
out throw away on social media
it's a lot of garbage dude like
it's cool when you see high quality
stuff on instagram i feel like
i feel like barracks is the best follow
on instagram bear dude i love it yeah
like they're showing up like five six
times a day on my feet and it's a good
good way to stay up to date i did on
instagram barracks i like first and then
and then and then what like no matter
what i support them i love them and
never yeah yeah i mean dude there's so
much content in skateboarding we think
about it skateboarding has probably a
huge [ __ ]
percentage of ownership on instagram
with content like dude like
instagram's hyped on skating because
because so much content is posted yeah
you know right but um to me
i i think i think the the single-handed
most valuable thing is saving a video
part putting a video apart but it's hard
to hold shelf life now you don't have
the dvd copy right you know and you're
being put in a mix of people on youtube
right video parts coming out every day
how could you stand
out and like give that
value
and
bigger bang has only been out for two
days as we've recovered right now yeah
yeah and and how many views does it have
um
i i couldn't tell you because i didn't
put this on youtube
it thrasher exclusive it's it's on
thrasher um it it's what i did this time
was i i actually put it out
independently so it's on its own website
biggerbangvideo.com okay the first time
a video
has its own
house
his own place to live okay so that's
that was my way to
and it doesn't live on youtube
nah
wow i mean anyone could put it up there
which like i'm waiting for that but i
didn't put it up there
that's it that almost seems crazy to me
like like uh because like the views the
count
uh
it's actually i can't track
i can't track it and um no one can see
it it it it wasn't about the views you
know it was about man how how could this
like sit somewhere where it it's gonna
be there like 10 years later still
sitting there i think that youtube
checks that box and and being like the
ultimate attention [ __ ] that i am
i i like
i'm all about the views
but to answer your question too yeah
like shelf life like video parts now
need to be
so epic so [ __ ] such an event like
nige's till death part that was a
[ __ ] event oh my god and i can't say
that nigel's death part is any less
like explosive than your parts it's just
different like it was just pure burl you
know it's unforgettable it changed the
game yeah it raised the bar it's pure
burl
but for me the style of skating that i
love is just that flip and flip out
you know it's just what i that's what i
love i mean dude am i correct that in
your true part you did a kick flip back
side lip slide two kick flip back side
lip slide yeah
i mean dude
yeah i did yeah
that that's one that's one thing that
you didn't uh raise the bar on with the
new apartment i did i didn't keep foot
back side lip slide to kick my back side
tail slide right right right right right
okay
but but
the kick flip back side lip slide the
kick flip back side lip slide kick flip
out
is is here
oh it's just so
that that's that that's the mission that
yeah
wow dude it's just it gives me anxiety i
think you're right the the kickback
backside lip side to
kick flip backside tail slide there is
no slouching maneuver
no no no but dude i mean it it's still
it's like dude
if you could flip in flip on and flip
out that's your that's your upgrade yeah
that's all i want to get i want to get
that one dude like
it sounds crazy but i'm dead serious
about it yeah
so uh yeah i did i love it but
i don't know dude i stopped doing all
that ledge dancing combo [ __ ] for a
while
you know like i felt like it was kind of
getting played out i mean i don't know
i don't get bored of it but like i don't
know i love it to me it's the challenge
it's so frustrating dude that frontside
flip front blunt there's a frontside
flip front nose blunt that just went on
forever like dude it's just oh yeah yeah
yeah the long ass one i can't get enough
of it i i can't get enough i i have fun
going the distance
what's going on with daewon these days
dude
dude day one is
the [ __ ] man dude he skates every day
he skates every day dude he spits every
day he doesn't he doesn't age a day ever
did he just do a bose commercial or a um
some music commercial
i don't know maybe it's just everyone's
been in some [ __ ] lately dude i don't
know he's been in like a couple like
like uh uh uh
cartoons and like
using like another little like tv show i
love it
yeah dude he came out with that that
documentary
it's called day one yep like um he's
he's classic dude i mean
it's rad he's uh just so inspirational
he gave he he believed in me man he gave
me this chance dude he's got some
experience with the skateboard companies
too right didn't he run almost yeah he
started a lot of companies man um i
skated for almost for three years
i had to leave almost to get on plan b
right and then when i left plan b he
left almost and we kind of full circle
came together
didn't he start the a team with mullen
yeah
that was very disrupting dude
how so what do you mean because uh
rodney muller was on plan b and he like
left when he had a video part for the
new plan b video coming out and it was
kind of like
you know it
there's a lot of times skaters leave
companies to start other companies where
they're burning the company that they
were at it was it was perceived by the
industry as
rodney mullen burned plan b much the
same way it was
perceived as
a burn
when uh carol
left
was it it's like leaving the gang
started
leaving to start the girl skateboards
was it was a gnarly yeah i don't know i
wasn't around those days you know so i
can't say but um
yeah i do and dude there's feelings
there's always going to be feelings when
that [ __ ] happens right it's like
it's it's it's you turned your back on
your brothers dude is it like that or i
think i mean i don't think like feelings
can be there man i think like when the
guys started girl i think there were
those feelings when when uh mullen left
plan b to start the a team i think there
were those well because they take the
riders with them
yeah but can't just be like talking and
that's we can make eight dollars aboard
over here
[Applause]
[ __ ] dude pay him more money hope that
they do that [ __ ] open the books let me
see what you're making on the boards i
mean i think that at the very least and
i'll say this to the whole skateboard
industry at large like
draw a line
a distinction between retail board sales
and direct to consumer online board
sales because you're just stealing from
your riders if you don't
100 percent i mean direct-to-consumer is
such a big market these days such a
[ __ ] huge
in the margins like yeah i'm gonna draw
a little double if not triple like if
you could separate that board royalty
right there for the rider yeah like it's
huge i mean i mean but like like why
don't we or do it all in one go by
giving a percentage of net profits yeah
then that's gonna that's gonna get it or
everybody do it themselves because
they're that's like that's what we're
seeing happening and and and all of the
skateboard companies that are failing to
recognize this
are losing their riders because their
writers are going starting their own
companies as they should like tori did
like nige did and i just started
disorder
torrey started thank you p-rod started
primitive i mean like nigel they're
probably being very gracious with naija
giving them five dollars aboard when he
was probably like what the [ __ ] i mean
that's like the as high as you can
probably go i i don't know i mean if
that was the case why would he have left
and started disorder because it's five
dollars a board right because they were
that now
yeah there's no they are being gracious
at night just being gracious to niger
yeah and i really like that you did it
yourself because like i think a lot of
people i mean anybody can do it i mean
it's really [ __ ] hard to start your
own business but like
not anybody can do it and and like
danny's not lying when he says
there's there's not a lot of money in
hard goods it's uh there's razor thin
margins there's tons of competition yeah
don't forget about the international
market you're already giving them a
discount right out the gates off
wholesale you know right like
you're like really barely making any
money i mean like some of the biggest
like accounts you have it's like dude
we're
we're like bending over backwards for
you guys and we're making peanuts dude
right it's it's so much competition for
thank you thank you so there are so many
pros there are so many companies that
like yeah you can make like the instead
of two bucks a board you could be making
eight 10 even 20 bucks a board on direct
to consumer however
it's a [ __ ] pretty small number of
boards that you're able to sell with all
that competition and
you know
yeah dude and you got a lot of expense
getting in there you're taking a big
gamble on yourself by opening your own
company and that's why tory's sitting
here four years into it and it's like ah
i enjoy the process of it just like i do
skating you know like it's like for me
it's fun to kind of like i'm going
through college right now like just
educating myself right uh and dude it's
it's such a wild experience of just like
[ __ ] up and making mistakes and then
fixing them and like dude it's like
putting a puzzle together but i'm
getting good at it getting better at it
have you thought about kind of
a future
like taking a page out of durdik's
playbook where you're like now that
you've learned about companies maybe you
could consult
well maybe you could just
apply what you've learned in business to
companies that have nothing to do with
skateboarding
and set yourself up for the future in
that regard um
dude i never thought about that dude i'm
still so like focused on like like
i want to keep my skate career going for
as long as i can
i did so much work dude to like
double dip
right to like do a company and skate and
like dude sure that was red mullen had
that problem dude i don't chill like i
got no time to kick it dude i've been
like you're talking to two guys who do
not chill either like i did like you
know but i love it dude right i love
hanging out with people that that just
are always always it's the hustle man
yeah it's side hustle i mean dude that's
that's what we are it's like we we've
built everything in our lives because
it's like it's [ __ ] we wanted to do you
know and you got to work hard for it so
like yeah starting a board brand it's
like
i'm just working hard for it regardless
if it makes it anywhere or not like dude
i'll be real dude like
i took no money from the company i
sacrificed my well i mean like i
sacrificed my salary when i moved on
from plan b
and like
dude for me to feel comfortable to give
myself a paycheck took so [ __ ] long
and i still don't do it consistently
well
is it not fair to say
that
to keep the company afloat that you've
taken your own money from other areas to
put into the company
so whatever whatever that too yeah so
whatever money you've taken out of the
company is chicken [ __ ] compared to the
money that you've taken from other areas
to put into yeah and the work it takes
to get that back too so then the company
can sustain itself without that
little booster yeah personal equity
sweat equity it takes [ __ ] time dude
like straight debt i got to imagine
but like dude like the big thing when i
started this company
and like i was telling damon this is
like dude like i'm not i'm not doing it
to get rich you know i want to do it to
take care of like our family so everyone
who skates for for thank you like our
team
like
taking care of very well you know and
like
when the money comes in here very well
three bucks aboard
for sure
i mean like i think that if you were to
is it if you were to take the
the definition of
the nature of the board sales and say
hey you know for direct to consumer
because the margin's so much greater
we're going to give you a big a bigger
board royalty i mean i just think that
just makes sense and and it's got to
happen yeah
it's it's tough it's tough dude with
with just like like you said dude you're
like fighting for shelf space at the
skate shop yeah you know but but direct
to consumer it's like
man how much you gotta like how cool you
gotta be to get people to go on your
website and buy a board it's like really
the skaters that are getting that
traffic there you know yeah social media
putting all their skate footage on the
on the internet can we can we drive
traffic to to get some board sales
on your website
where do we where do they go is it thank
you skateboards.com thank you
skatecode.com yeah thank you
skatecode.com
and you sell completes on there yeah how
much you sell like a complete board for
for dude we got them on sale
for the guy you know what i'm saying for
how much we got them we got them on sale
outfitted with venture trucks huh
there's adventure trucks the completes
no i wish i wish dude then we couldn't
put it on
how much you saw complete for just in on
average uh what it would what it would
retail for would be 110 bucks so 110
bucks that's [ __ ] crazy yeah so
completes have good margin yeah i want
to do like some sort of a giveaway
ccs the what ccs the trucks nah do the
trucks say thank you on them which is
kind of like dude it's kind of [ __ ]
to do so you get your wheels
cool to do that but like they look legit
like it's just branded thank you on the
truck they're not thank you trucks but
like
but it's but it but it's branded thank
you on the track
but they look exactly like dude i swear
to god they're independents how do i
make it how do i make it work where if
somebody's listening and and they don't
have a skateboard and i want to buy them
skateboard could i
give you
like go on your website and buy three
completes for somebody to skate from
your website is that possible is there a
way they can email you or something like
that of course you go to thank you
skatecode.com
yeah but i want to pay for uh like a
skater kid to get a complete board or
something like that you do i do uh well
i wouldn't i would be more happy to give
it to you no no i would be more happy to
go online and pay for it but are you
saying that by buying three do you get a
lower price i just want to do like a
giveaway three completes i want to pay
for them and then give them away to a
fan that's that's love and support yeah
yeah
thank you skatecode.com
boom we got our web store cool so you
can market market as a gift is that yeah
i'm wondering how i do that like if
somebody's listening doesn't have a
skateboard and they want a skateboard
and they go on the website oh and and is
that a box of boards right there
um that's a board i i brought you a
board sick man i i may pull it out yeah
dude yeah open that [ __ ] up i i made it
i made it for you uh it's a one of one
wow it's a one
that's the kind of [ __ ] i like to do man
i like i have fun
i have fun doing it that so this is this
is uh uh
boards we made for the video release
bigger bang
which which
which are on the bigger bang video dot
com
and um so that that was my way stevo to
kind of do something different
because like
videos are free now we don't make any
money off this hard work that we're
putting in we're just giving these
videos out for free and then you're
screening the boards yourself you said
that when you're listening to the the
danny way episode of our podcast that
you were in the middle of screaming
boards yeah yeah that's the same that's
what i did here this is special with the
black roses on it that's the only one
like that it's just kind of like a
yeah i love it
that was a happy accident right there
how i i figured out how to put these
roses on it which is i love it man never
seen nothing like that before never got
to get you to sign it and and that makes
me wonder too [ __ ] the secret to how i
sell so many skateboards through my
website is that i sign every one of them
i mean dude
you don't want to devalue that your name
though man
well i seize myself every time you sign
your name dude you devalue it a little
bit
then my [ __ ] isn't worth nothing
yeah uh but but what does that mean
i'll be i'll be straight with you dude
like if you put out a board and you're
selling it online and that [ __ ] signed
like
i i would be
to the chase to buy one of those for
sure i would do we'd like uh because
that's rare we have a fork
just the fact that you're putting boards
out the floor
people are doing that [ __ ] is such a
cool thing and like collecting boards
right now it's [ __ ] it's popping off
it's art yeah i do it yeah dude i'll
spend like three four hundred just to
get a [ __ ] sick board
knoxville and i did a collab skateboard
we both signed
every one of them and and it like people
people love it and now i got it got one
epic are you going to do a little tease
i got
it's your own [ __ ] i i i add value to
the stuff that i sign and i get a kick
out of it
like like dvds are our kick i sign every
dvd i sign every book yeah like like i
sign everything because i [ __ ] do not
man i mean it feels good
it helps me get my [ __ ] out there yeah
and like particularly with my books
particularly with my dvds i want i'm so
proud of them i want to get them out
there so bad that i just sit there and
sign all day i mean the signature is a
certificate of authenticity dude
calm there's so much signed [ __ ] like uh
i love it and you did so you didn't know
i wondered too like
like you you signed the board then all
the bigger bang boards they come sign
okay there you go when when uh what
if people get them
let's get let's get it
but it's hard man it's like dude like
you know like
the least i could ask for like is just
like the video is free and if like you
could please support by by getting one
of the boards like that's that's the way
yeah just like dude like
you know i love it
let me ask you this it's hard being a
skater these days yeah i'm just playing
let me ask let me ask you this with with
with the adversity that comes with
running your own company
and and and i get it with all of the
battle for shelf space with like all of
the you know
the
expenses of the company like did you
have to
fight any urges to put out your bigger
bank part sooner like like the company
needs the boost you know like
was there ever a thought like [ __ ] it
would help my skateboard company if i
just put this [ __ ] video out um
well
obviously the goal is the video comes
out it will boost the brand they're sure
but but
the quality of the video
uh
is more important and then the quality
because i could have put out three video
parts with it yeah well how long was it
finished how long did you have it
finished and then you waited to put it
out i broke my ankle in december that's
where i it
drew the line to say [ __ ] it dude i'm
done filming i'm gonna put this thing
out i don't know if i said this before
but but
you did
outdo
the true part like you you have outdone
yourself and thanks man i i
i don't know i i definitely feel like
like that true part was like
everything i had in me like i wanted to
[ __ ]
i felt like i was like in hell i hated
life filming for that video because dude
you're in it dude and it's just you're
so deep in it dude and you're just like
you don't stop till you're done and that
one i got to fully finish and execute
with everything i wanted
this new part
i mean i did i definitely went hard but
like but like but like i wasn't done yet
and i don't know when i would have put
it out that's the thing i could have
kept going for them
that uh that was a switch kickflip crook
was the ender after the
360 flip yeah
i i i would have been happy with you
settled down the backside flip over the
picnic table
oh me too dude me too uh that was one
switch kick flip crook
i mean dude i've been skating for a
while now you know and like i i'm i'm
not i'm not 10 or i'm not 21.
you know i'm i'm 32. and that's like
to me to me i'm like
i i did reach a point where i'm like
dude i am getting older you know i am i
am really kind of feeling this now you
know in my body and i was like damn dude
you got 32 year old jumping down 10
stairs over like i was like so i was
like dude i i still got it man i'm still
i'm still so that said that's the
philosophy of yeah i'm not only keeping
it low to the ground you know oh dude
you went higher and higher dude there's
so many ridiculously highly to me the
philosophy for that ender was um that
spot hasn't been skated in 15 years
and we went there we cracked the knobs
off that thing made it skateable again
nobody knew about it kept it on the dl
for about a year didn't tell nobody and
i went there to get my trick
in like 110 degree heat dude
didn't get it that day i heat stroke
dude almost crashed on my way home dude
because i was just so like out of it i
was like fading out just tired and then
i went back i couldn't walk for a whole
week went back the next weekend man
battled it again dude i had to get there
like eight in the morning before that he
it was like dude you know when there was
a heat wave
yeah dude this is in the suburbs too
yeah when it's like it's about a year
ago dude a year ago last summer i
[ __ ] got that [ __ ] dude i stopped it
and i was just so stoked because it was
just the the fact
that
something that that that is to me
looking at it
is is
like i was dying to skate there and and
it was brought back from the dead and i
got to be the guy
that hit it
right so it's like when people see that
spot they're like oh [ __ ] yeah
people are gonna go attack it now that
they'll uh
call things hubba's that are like low
and not really a hub but this thing is
like [ __ ] way gnarlier than a hubbub
dude that that was that was that thing
was pretty and it was a switch kick flip
crook yeah
the first one i put my feet on the board
was that one i rolled away too it's a
struggle can't can what's the
significance of the the song you picked
um there were three songs three songs
yeah uh
to be honest
like music and skate videos is the most
important thing that makes the skate
video obviously the skateboarding and
the filming and the editing all go into
it but if you got shitty music dude like
it ruins your part it's like dude i've
seen videos for the last five ten years
where it's like
amazing [ __ ] and i watch it and i get so
bummed because i'm like dude like what a
waste man like you don't really care to
like have this sit
on the shelf
have the value and be remembered
i remember skate videos for the music
dude yeah i got in a certain music from
skateboarding dude
i i wanted
i wanted to use music that i wanted to
use
and um i wanted to make sure that that
that
it was heavy
you know anyone using elvis you know
what i'm saying like
good time to use elevators yeah i opened
the video up to do it with tori dude
right in those elvis lights you know i
wanted like that moment i wanted to feel
like that you know
yeah so i love it to me what my skating
feels like to me is like
i don't know man i just want to be the
best me i could be that's it that's cool
[ __ ] yeah all right so we're gonna send
everybody right now to buy a [ __ ]
skateboard from thank you
skatecode.com yep
and there are no signed ones there
um these bigger bang
boards are signed bigger bang video but
we do we do sign boards
here and there all right me and day one
all right
and uh dude i didn't ask about grizzly
that's my baby grizzlies that's my baby
yeah i started it when i was um
11. that's got to be a [ __ ] one
that's got to be a money maker right
well dude it's i mean once again dude
we're we're not like
starting these companies with like all
this crazy education on how we're gonna
make something work so it's like in
business we have all these ups and downs
but it's a i mean it's a beast it's a
huge company
yeah you know what i mean and and you
learn you learn you learn the hard way
right you know what i mean you have your
struggles you got your ups your downs
like but grizzly man we're
we're like about to go on 12 years like
officially
as a as a business
that's that's that's a long time to
really like
but you know
we're uh
we're we're definitely like
a griptape company that innovated the
game for sure you changed the game did
shake jump straight copied your style
well they were around before us oh we're
there for us fair enough
no technically i i started my [ __ ] in
2001 when i was when i was 11.
so i have my shift i have my [ __ ]
forever just making accusations but
starting a war but like
i i got all love for like skateboard
company for sure there's other companies
that it's like
all right you know you're you're you're
a company for skateboards but you're not
like a skate company like where's your
raw
like real skate [ __ ] who owns your [ __ ]
who's running your [ __ ] like you guys
are kind of corporation you know like
right
and um
that's what's cool about companies like
grizzly and and shake you know it's like
for sure it's definitely pure skating
dude we're yeah dude i mean we're just
us man yeah like trying to do it and and
you know trying our best
it's [ __ ] hard man
we we have got to put the links to your
[ __ ] to to biggerbang.com yeah you got
bigger bang bang
i tried dude okay that [ __ ] was taken
what is it bigger bang video
biggerbangvideo.com
and the links in the description yep as
is thank you skate code be careful if
they go to
biggerbang.com make sure they add the
video on there yeah
the kids watching but yeah dude that's
hilarious so um grizzly grip tape
gray's like dripping skate co
yeah dude i mean
i it's crazy because what are you doing
for wheels i never i never tried to
start a company besides thank you
obviously but like dude i never
i never like
tried to do this [ __ ] you know what i
mean like kind of just happened
and like
two i don't know i don't think i
understood it at first like dude
a businessman you know like yeah it's
heavy you know what i mean like
from a future like you know what i mean
like what skate forever i thought but
like
man i really learned like
dude
it was like the smartest thing i ever
did i applaud you because i do believe
that you are legitimately in college
right now and that everything that you
learn from all of this struggling with
the business is going to pay dividends
down the road i think that it makes
sense like thanks man
when skating's not on the table anymore
like i think that uh you know you could
really look to what rob dyrdek has done
and uh yeah apply all of this valuable
knowledge and really set yourself up for
the future i would love that because i
love to work hard you know yeah yeah and
even even like
even if i'm like
working in a warehouse one day printing
skateboards
to make a paycheck
dude i i love that too you know because
skateboarding the one thing that it gave
me
was a work ethic i couldn't have got
that from nothing else i think that i
could say the same thing skateboarding
weeds out quitters gave me a straight
work ethic and like man i don't know i
love to kind of influence other people
around me you know because they always
tell me like dude like
man like
you're killing it dude like i want to be
like you man like i'm just like dude
well then you gotta work yeah you gotta
do the work i got the people that i'm
influenced by and like
i i
i never thought they just like got it
like that you know like i see how much
they work and i'm like damn dude yeah
what [ __ ] hey man dude i i i've
decided that uh i'm gonna make this my
skateboard lamp
oh that's sick yeah that's what's up
we'll show you what we're talking about
yeah
that's what's up
hey
it's it's crazy that we met up and we
did this off of like
yeah i don't know i was gonna hit you up
i was stressed
as [ __ ] i was gonna hit you up to see if
i could be on the podcast but you hit me
up to be on the podcast and i ran into
you the first time i met you yeah but
then i seen you again yeah and i was
like damn dude me and stephen were like
cosmic bros
it's crazy
hey respect to uh how [ __ ] sick you
are as a skater too oh man straight up
straight up
straight up
how about that another episode in the
can with my favorite skateboarder ever
dare i love this guy
so
if you've made it this far to the end of
the podcast you know i love you and if
you've done so without having seen this
man tori pod will skate then please
enjoy his work man you can start off
with uh a youtube search for big bang
tori pudwell
if then that that will blow your mind
then you see his next one which was uh
the plan b video true tori pudwell plan
b true video and then just out like
three days ago boom tori pudwell bigger
bang
it's so mind-blowing dude i love it so
much and uh what else i'm out of here
tomorrow which for you guys many of you
is today
uh to go back on tour man i'll be on
tour for uh like 10 days only
um
i'm touring my ass off for the rest of
the year find my dates at stevo.com and
i love you all thank you